rescue teams have suspended their search
for survivors of Friday's mining dam
collapse amid fears that get another
nearby dam could burst in Brazil's
southeast the death toll from the
collapsed dam has risen to at least 37
with around 300 people still missing
firefighters have been digging through
the debris trying to find survivors but
hopes of finding more people live or
fading it's still unclear what caused
the dam to burst correspondent Mateus a
bouts is in the town of Broome adeno
that's near the site of Friday's dam
collapse Mateus first off what can you
tell us about this risk of yet another
breach at a nearby mine it happened this
morning around 4 5 5 o'clock early when
all people were sleeping here in Bruma
jigna when alarm signal work was hurt
and many people many many people here
went out on the streets they looked for
position on top of the hills in order to
be on a good position if a new mudslide
should appear this was the fee many
people had this morning it was an alarm
signal from Valley the mine company here
they feared another dam could break but
so far we didn't we can't say that this
happened it was everything calm today so
no new catastrophe happened today but
what we know is that the river behind me
is now full of the mad full of chemicals
from from the the minor mining company
so we see here that fish and so on so it
is already a ecological catastrophe
which is happening right now let's talk
about what's the environmental impact
here I mean and this is this mud it's
essentially mining waste I mean how
dangerous is that so far we can't say
what is exactly the content of the mud
but the company said in the in the
beginning it's only a sand and water
but now we see dead fish as we see that
the impact is right looks the same like
mariana three years ago close by here
another incident which happened another
catastrophe
which was the biggest one in Brazil's
history so we expect that there will be
a lot of consequences in their member
our mental surroundings of Roma Gino and
further downwards the the the river so
we will see in the next days what indeed
will be the content of the rivers now
flooded what can you tell me about this
company Valley that's behind these dams
they've been involved in other mining
catastrophes in the past right yeah well
it was once a public company and then
they turned private and since then the
accusations from environmentalists don't
stop accusation accusing them Valley of
of not respecting enough environmental
obstacles and issues they should not
care enough on these aspects is this is
what I'm Mara mentalist say so the
company has not the best reputation so
far but they are real big iron ore
exporter and with rising prices their
production rose and this is a really a
big player here in Brazil and worldwide
and at the markets
yeah the shares are and now under
pressure alright Matias a birthday for
us in Brazil thank you very much